so the first thing i want to show you is
this thing called a galton board
now
the the this was worked out by francis
galton who's actually quite an
interesting person you'll you'll if you
hear about francis colton you'll often
hear that he was the first person who
tried to
measure human intelligence but that's
actually not true what golden tried to
do was measure human eminence
and he thought of eminence as i suppose
something like high position in the
cultural dominance hierarchy and this
was back in victorian england in the
late 1800s and so
eminence would have been intellectual
achievement financial achievement
cultural achievement achievement broadly
speaking but really considered within
the confines of a dominance hierarchy
so at that point in time
the english regarded themselves as the
prime
nation and ethnicity on the planet and
then the aristocratic englishmen
regarded themselves as the prime human
beings in that prime country in
ethnicity and so it was really
an idea that would be more associated
with with dominance hierarchy
uppermost dominance hierarchy position
than anything we would conceptualize as
intelligence today
and golden got golton was a a polymath
he was a genius in many many fields and
he got very interested in the idea of
measuring human differences and
he tried to
determine whether the differences that
he could measure and some of those
things were like reaction time and
height and
physical fitness and
i can't remember all the other things
that he attempted to measure but he
wanted to see if any of those things
could be used to predict eminence
um turned out that
they couldn't partly because eminence
is not
the kind of category that you can make
into a scientific category
and partly because his measurement
instruments
in many ways weren't sensitive enough he
didn't make enough measurements and the
statistics weren't sufficiently
sophisticated
but the idea that you could measure
elementary attributes and that you could
use them to predict something important
was still
an important idea and it's one of those
examples in science sort of like
phrenology i mean everyone makes fun of
phrenology now you know the idea that
you could read someone's character by
mapping out the protrusions and dips and
so forth on the on their skull
it sounds
ridiculous
to modern ears but
there was again there was some idea
behind it and that was the idea that
cortical functions could be localized
and that
cognitive functions could be
differentiated into separate functions
we still do that we think of emotions
and motivations and personality traits
and intelligences even though
intelligence is not a very good idea the
idea that you can differentiate
human psychological function and then
that would be related in some way to the
underlying neurological and physical
architecture that's not a stupid idea so
an idea can be very intelligent at one
level of analysis and not so intelligent
at the other so i would say the problem
with the phrenologist was actually a
problem of operationalization
they had the theory right in some sense
but they didn't have the measures right
um
now one of the things galton came up
with was the normal
he came up with this thing called a
galton board and a galton board
demonstrates how a normal distribution
is produced
now basically what you the normal
distribution is a
an axiomatic
it's an axiom of modern statistics and
every system has to have its axioms
and
the axiom of normal distribution is
basically the idea that around any
measurement there's going to be a set
there's going to be variations in
measurement and those measurements are
basically going to be random and then
another axiom is that extreme outlying
measurements are going to be rare and
small outlying measurements are going to
be more common so you can imagine
if i measured any one of you
a hundred times with a with uh let's say
with a tape measure i'm going to get a
set of variables that are not always
exactly the same
and so there'll be an average and then
there'll be some deviation around that
average and if i
looked at 100 measurements that i took
of each of one of you then i would get a
normal distribution around that
that distribution and that's sort of the
fuzziness of the mean
now that might be partly because my
measurement instrument isn't very
accurate it might be partly because at
some point when you're being measured
for the 50th time you're slouching a
little bit or maybe other times you're
standing up a bit straighter or maybe i
measure you in the morning sometimes and
in the evening at other times and you're
actually taller in the morning than you
are in the evening because your spine
has a chance to decompress at night so
maybe that adds half an inch to your
height in the morning and so there's
there's going to be shifting and
movement around the
around the central tendency around the
average now if i turns out if i measure
all of you
the same thing's going to happen what
we're going to get is an average height
which would be the average height of the
people in this room and then there's
going to be a distribution and basically
a normal distribution
those of you who are much taller than
the average are going to be much fewer
than those of you that are close to the
average and those of you that are much
shorter than the average are going to be
there's going to be far fewer of you
than there are going to be
those of you who are just somewhat
smaller than the average now
generally the idea of a normal
distribution is predicated on the idea
that the variation around the average is
actually random
and that's an important thing because
the variation around an average is not
always random
now psychologists will tell you and
and so will most social scientists who
use classical statistics that the normal
distribution is the norm or maybe
they'll say more than that is that it's
the standard case that whatever set of
variables you measure is going to come
out in a normal distribution and that
means that you can apply all of the
stats that you're going to learn to
decompose the world and reconstruct it
to your data sets because the data sets
will fit the assumptions of the
of the um statistics the problem with
that is that it's often wrong
now
i ask you guys to buy the black swan
and we haven't talked about the black
swan much yet and i'm not going to test
you on it but i would recommend that you
that you read it especially if you're
interested in psychology because
you got to watch your axioms and the
idea that the normal distribution might
not always be correct and certainly
might not be a correct description of
your data is a fundamentally important
idea because if it's wrong if your data
isn't normally distributed then the
phenomena that you're looking at isn't
what you think it is and the statistics
that you're going to use aren't going to
work
now this came as quite a puzzle to me at
one point because it turned out that
when we
when we produced the creative
achievement questionnaire
um
you know and you'd think i would have
known better by this time because it was
it wasn't that long ago it was like 15
years ago
the data never came back normally
distributed it came back distributed in
a you know what they call a pareto
distribution which is everyone stacks up
on the left hand side and
the the curve drifts off to the right
and that's one of those curves where
almost everyone has zero or one and a
small minority of people have very high
scores
now when you get a pareto distribution
there's something going on that's not
random
and that doesn't mean you can ignore it
now one of the things that psychologists
will do sometimes if they get a
distribution that's not random is
they'll do a mathematical transformation
like a logarithmic transformation to
pull in the outliers and to try to make
the data fit the normal distribution
again
assuming that there's some kind of
measurement error or that the scale's
got a logarithmic function
it isn't always obvious that that's a
useful
and appropriate thing to do
because
it's the case
in many situations where
the extremeness of the distribution is
actually an accurate representation of
of the way that that phenomena behaves
in nature now i want to show you how a
normal distribution works
have you ever have any of you ever seen
a demonstration of why
a normal distribution is normal and why
it takes the shape it takes
has anybody ever seen that
no it's weird eh because you'd think
that given its unbelievable importance
especially in psychology where
everything we do is measured and has an
average and a standard deviation that
there'd be some investigation into why
we make that presupposition there's a
great book
one book i would recommend for those of
you who might be interested in
psychology as a career there's a book
called a history of statistical thinking
now you'd think jesus if there's not
anything more boring than statistics
it's got to be the history of statistics
but it turns out that that's really
wrong i mean the history of statistics
is actually the history of the social
sciences and not only of the social
sciences because statistics became auto
statistics was actually
initially
invented by cosmologists who were
measuring planetary position
and then
the statistical processes that have been
used to underpin modern science have
been tossed back and forth weirdly
enough between social scientists and
physicists over about the last 200 years
because the physicists ended up having
to describe the world from a statistical
perspective right because if you go down
into the realm of the atomic and
subatomic particles what you find is
that things behave statistically down
there they don't behave
deterministically and it's the same at
the level of the of the human scale you
know we behave statistically not
deterministically so you know sometimes
you hear this old idea that that
psychology has physics envy or something
like that but it turned out that for
much of the history of the development
of statistical ideas physics had
psychology envy which i think is quite
funny so anyways if you look at this
book historic history of statistical
thinking you can see
how the idea that populations could have
behavior and that populations could be
measured and that the idea that states
like political states could be measured
and that human behavior could be
measured and
i didn't realize until i wrote i read
this book that um how revolutionary the
idea of statistics actually was because
of course it's part of the idea of
measurement
so
i had this very interesting client at
one point he was an old guy and he'd
been a psychologist and a financier and
a statistician and he was in love with
mathematics you know he was one of these
guys who who for whom mathematical
equations had this immediate glimmer of
beauty and he made this very interesting
little gold sculpture that i have up in
my office that that's a representation
of what people claim to be the most
perfect mathematical equation ever
constructed and
so we made this little gadgets like a
religious icon almost and
that's really what he thought of it and
um
i'm afraid foolishly enough that i can't
tell you the name of the equation some
of you might know it it it relates i e
and pi
is there anybody in here yes what is
that
yes and what is that equation
okay do you do you know why it's such a
remarkable equation
in one equation right so he thought that
in some sense this equation summed up
the magnificence of the mathematical
universe and so it was so funny because
he also made little pins that people
could wear of this of this equation that
we're also made out of gold and there
was another person in our department at
that point and uh i was wearing this pin
around and she said oh well she told me
what the equation was she pointed at
that and she got all excited because it
was this perfect equation that related
all these fundamental constants to one
and zero so
anyways he taught me a lot of this well
he was a client of mine he was very much
obsessed with mathematical ideas he
couldn't get them out of his head it was
a true obsession and a useful one but he
had he taught me a lot of things about
statistics that i just never knew at all
and uh
one of them was the pareto distribution
which just it just staggered me that i
didn't know it i only learned this stuff
about five or six years ago and it just
made me feel like a complete
because i'd you know gone through
men's not immense amount of
psychological training and i was
measuring things like prefrontal ability
and intelligence and personality and
creativity and then in the creativity
measurement i stumbled into these pareto
distributions i thought they were a
bloody mistake i didn't know what the
hell they were you know and i've also
found economists who didn't know about
the pareto distribution which is a
pretty bloody bizarre thing like it
really is a strange thing
so anyways
one of the things he showed me is how
the normal distribution comes about and
uh i had a student who did a phd thesis
on galton so i knew something about
galton at this point he was he was doing
a part of his thesis on the history of
the measurement of intelligence
and uh
galton was a key figure in the
establishment of that sort of
measurement so
but this is one of the things galton
invented so
let's take a look at it here
okay so
that's your basic rock and roll
galton board
apparently
so let me show you a picture of of a
galton board so you get a better sense
of
exactly what it is doing
so there's a good one right there
let's see if we can make that a little
bigger
yeah
so basically all that happens with the
galton board is that you have a
you have a bunch of pegs on a board
board is horizontal and you drop balls
down at marbles or whatever it is and
the marbles come at in one place and
then they bounce down the pins
and they distribute themselves in a
normal distribution
now the reason they do that is because
there are far more ways of getting down
the middle than there are of getting to
either side
now you see because to get to the
only to the right side say the ball has
to go right right right right right
right right right and then fall in the
little
cup and then on the left it has to do
exactly the same thing there's only one
way it can do that
right but to get into the middle it can
go left right left right left right
right left etc there's a there's a far
greater number of pathways for the ball
to go from the middle down to the middle
than there is for the ball to go to the
sides and so all that means
fundamentally is that the probability
that a given ball is going to land in
the middle or near the middle is much
higher than the probability that a ball
is going to land in the extremes
and so it's just a description of how
random processes lay themselves out
around a mean
okay so that's a normal distribution now
if you have normal distribution one
and you have normal distribution two
you can overlap them right and if they
overlap perfectly the mean and the
standard deviation are the same then
there's nothing different about them you
know because one thing you want to ask
is well are how do you know if two means
are different and the answer is you
don't know unless you know what the
means are measuring and you don't know
what the means are measuring unless you
know the variation of the measurement
and so you have to know the mean and the
standard deviation so the standard
deviation is like the width of the mean
in some sense
and all statistics do generally speaking
is take one normal distribution and
another and slap them on top of each
other
and then measure how far apart they are
how much they overlap
and correct that for the sample size
and then you can tell if the two
distributions are different
significantly different so what you
would do is you run a whole bunch of
normal distribution processes by chance
and you're going to get a distribution
of distributions in some sense and then
you can tell what the probability is
that the normal distribution that you
drew for group a is the same as the
normal distribution that you drew for
group b
and that's all there is basically to to
standard group comparison statistics
and that's how we decide when we have a
significant effect if there's a
significant difference between two
groups or
better still
if you randomly assign people to two
groups and then you do an experimental
manipulation
and then you measure the outcome the
means then you can test to see whether
your experimental manipulation produced
an effect that would be
greater than chance and then you'd infer
that well
there's a low probability one in 20 that
you would you would um
produce that effect if you were just
running random simulations and therefore
you can say with some certainty that
there's an actual causal effect that's
with an experimental model now
you know why do you think all right
let's say let me give you a conundrum so
i used to study people who were sons of
male alcoholics
okay now there was a reason for that we
didn't have women
why might that be we didn't use women
why
why why would they be confounding apart
from the fact that they're women
that's supposed to be a joke you know
jesus it's a better joke than that okay
well it could be that
there's some sort of like uh
emotional coping mechanism that differs
between the way that men deal with
because the
father's daughter relationship is
different
okay well so that that's a plus that's
not a bad answer but it's it's not the
answer that was appropriate for our
research and i'll tell you why because
you couldn't infer it from the question
we were interested in
what factors made alcoholism hereditary
because it does seem to have a strong
hereditary component and what we
basically concluded after doing a
tremendous amount of research was that
people who are prone to alcoholism at
least one type of person who's prone to
one type of alcoholism
got a very very powerful stimulant
effect from the alcohol during the time
that their blood alcohol level was
ascending in the 10 or 15 minutes after
they took a drink especially if they
took a large drink
fast or multiple large drinks fast you
can probably tell by the way if you're
one of these people if you want to go do
this in the bar the next time you go
go on an empty stomach
take your pulse
write it down
drink three or four shots fast
wait 10 minutes take your pulse again if
it's gone up 10 or 15 beats a minute
look out
because that means alcohol is working as
a psychomotor stimulant for you and we
found that for many of these people that
was an opiate effect what seemed to
happen was that when they drank alcohol
fast
they produced probably beta endorphin
although we were never sure
it can be blocked with naltrexone which
is an opiate antagonist
anyways the other characteristic of that
pattern of of
of alcohol consumption is that
the the real kick only occurs when
you're on the ascending limb of the
blood alcohol curve so you know first of
all your blood alcohol goes up and then
it goes down and generally when it goes
down it's not pleasant that's when you
start to feel hungover and hangover is
actually alcohol withdrawal by the way
so it's like heroin withdrawal except
it's alcohol withdrawal and it's
generally not pleasant for people so
they usually sleep through it
or it puts them to sleep but if you're
one of these people who get a real kick
on the ascending limb of the blood
alcohol curve then you can just keep
pounding back the alcohol and it'll keep
hitting you and keep you in that
position where you're
you know on the on the ascending part of
the blood alcohol curve and you can
probably tell if you're one of these
people if you can't stop once you get
started
you know so if it's like you have four
drinks quick and it's like man you're
gone until the alcohol runs out or till
it's four in the morning or until you've
spent all your money or you've been at
the last bar in town or that you're
sitting on your friend's bed after
everybody's gone home from the party and
you're still drinking you might suspect
that you're one of those people and if
you are one of those people well then
you should watch the hell out because um
alcohol is a vicious drug and
it it gets people in its grasp hard and
it's hard for them to escape once they
do people also drink to quell anxiety
so now the problem
because we were looking at the genetics
of alcoholism
it wasn't easy to study offspring of
alcoholic mothers and the reason for
that is they might have consumed alcohol
during pregnancy
in which case and that's a bad idea
especially there are certain key times
in pregnancy where even a few drinks are
not good and that turns out if i
remember correctly that turns out to be
the times when the fetus is producing
the bulk of its hippocampal tissue and
so
anyway so if it turned out that
daughters or sons of female alcoholics
were
markedly different from the general
population in some manner we wouldn't be
able to tell if that was a consequence
of alcohol consumption during pregnancy
or if it was it was a genetic reflection
so what we wanted to do was study sons
of male alcoholics and so their mothers
actually couldn't be alcoholic
and we wanted their fathers the best
subjects had an alcoholic father and an
alcoholic grandfather and at least one
or more alcoholic first or second degree
male relatives and they couldn't be
alcoholic and they had to be young so
because
obviously if they were 40 and they still
weren't alcoholic then they probably
weren't going to be alcoholic so we
wanted to catch them you know between
say well it had to be 18 which was it
was in quebec
that was even a little late probably but
you know that's best we could do from an
ethical perspective so we used to bring
these guys into the lab and get them
quite drunk
the national institute of alcoholism and
alcohol abuse pretty much put a stop to
that research because we used to bring
them in and
you know we'd get their blood alcohol
level up to 0.12 or 0.10 it had to be
pretty high it actually looked like the
real physiological effects seem to kick
in
when
when people hit legal intoxication so
you don't really get the opiate effect
until you pop yourself up about 0.08
which was the legal limit for driving at
that point um
so we used to get some of these guys
were pretty big they'd come in they were
maybe 230 pound guys and to get them up
to
you know point one or point two you had
or point one two you had to give them
quite a bit quite a whack of alcohol and
then what we usually do is we let them
sober up till .06 about that and then
we'd send them home in a cab
well when the ni triple a got all
ethical on the whole situation they
wouldn't let us send them home until
they hit .02 it was like well if you're
240 pounds and we've just nailed you
with enough alcohol so that your blood
alcohol that will hit point one two
you're going to be sitting in our bloody
lab bored to death feeling horrible for
like six hours or seven hours and you'll
be pretty damn irritated about it it's
like it wasn't obvious how we were
supposed to keep the people there it's
like can i leave no
i'm not paying you if you leave it's
like that's going to produce real
positive outcomes with like drunk people
in the lab that's going to work really
well of course then they'd never come
back either because it was such a bloody
awful experience
so i stopped doing that research partly
because it became impossible anyways we
did find out a lot we found out that
there was this one particular pattern of
of alcohol abuse that seemed to be
hereditary
so and we couldn't study in women
anyway so now
there was a problem with this
line of research and the problem was
well alcoholism comes along with other
problems
so this was correlational research right
we take we we pick a group of people and
we'd match them the sons of male
alcoholics would match them with people
who weren't
sons of male alcoholics so they were
still sons they were still the same age
but their fathers weren't alcoholic now
here's the problem
what should we match them on
age
gender
well you can't match them on number of
drinks obviously because
you want the people who are alcoholic in
one group
not to be
you don't want alcoholics in the second
group so do you match them on number of
drinks
well if you don't then you don't know if
the effect that you're measuring is a
consequence of the genetic difference or
on the number of drinks per week or
drinks per occasion that the people had
right that would be a confounding
variable do you match them for
antisocial personality
or anti-person antisocial personality
symptoms because lots of people who are
alcoholic have they tilt towards the
antisocial side of the spectrum so do
you control for that
well you don't know because you don't
know if antisocial personality is part
of alcoholism like it's part of the same
underlying genetic problem or if it's a
secondary manifestation or if it's a
consequence of drinking you don't know
any of that do you match them on
depressive symptoms do you match them on
schooling you match them on education do
you match them on personality do you
match them on other forms of
psychopathology
do you match them on what they drink do
you match them on how many drinks per
occasion they drink when they drink
etc well the answer to that is
you don't know
and so what that means is there's
actually an infinite number of potential
covariance
because you don't know
what differences there are between the
two groups are the differences that are
relevant to the question at hand
now
that's actually one of the big problems
with psychiatric research in fact it
might be a problem with psychiatric
research that's so serious that it
cannot be solved you know so if you take
kids who are attention deficit disorder
say which is a horrible diagnostic
criteria and you match them with kids
who aren't
and then you look to see what the what
makes the adhd kids different
what do you match them on
well you don't know
and that is so usually what happens is
the people who do psychiatric research
finesse this a bit they match them on
the important variables
age
physical health maybe
education but the po the problem is you
actually have no idea what the important
variables are and there are an unlimited
number of them
and so that's actually why random
assignation to groups is so important
now if i take all of you
and i say well
let's look at the effects of alcohol
so what i would do is i'd say
you'd come towards me and i'd do a
golden board sorting you go to the left
you go to the right you go to the left
you go to the right this is non-biased
separation of the two populations and
then maybe i'd give one group
two ounces of alcohol in water and the
other or in coke say and in the other
group i put a few drops of alcohol on
the top of a glass of coke so it smelled
like alcohol and tasted like alcohol
when you had your first drink and then i
put you through a whole battery of
neuropsychological and personality tests
which i did by the way to a bunch of
people would i think it was the first
publication i had back in about 85 or
something like that um
random assignation
gets rid of the necessity for the
infinite number of covariance right
because you're all different in a whole
bunch of important ways but we could
assume as long as i threw half of you in
this group randomly and half of you in
that group randomly that all your
various idiosyncrasies no matter how
many there are would cancel out
and that's the massive advantage to
random assignation now one of the things
you're going to notice when you go
through psychology especially if you do
psychopathological work is that the
studies are almost always correlational
and they do they'll do they'll co
they'll control for relevant covariance
that's what it'll say in the paper but
the problem is you don't bloody well
know what the rand the relevant
covariates are if you did you'd already
understand the condition you wouldn't
have to do the damn research
so you can make a pretty strong case
that all psychiatric research that is
studying psychopathological groups
compared to act control it's all
not
interpretable
and it turns out in that kind of
research that who should who the control
should be is the killer
because you don't know
picking the
psychopathological population is easy
you just
pick them according to whatever
diagnostic checklist you happen to use
but when you figure out who to control
them against it's like
siblings i mean what do you what do you
do what do you how do you match a
population the answer is you can't
so
anyways the reason that we didn't
include women was because
of the
uh
on the uncontrollable potential
confounding effects and the only way
that you can do that is to assign
randomly and that's an important thing
to remember it's why
experimental designs are way more
powerful than correlational designs and
the problem is frequently in psychology
what you see are correlational designs
now i think if you're careful and you
dig around
and you know you're obsessively careful
you can extract information out of
correlational studies but it's no
it's no simple thing to do you see this
problem come up too when you hear about
studies on diet you know it's like well
you should eat a low-fat diet or you
should eat a high-fat diet or usually
what happens is they track people across
time
who hypothetically have been having one
diet or the other but the problem is you
don't know what the hell else makes
those people different
and the problem with that is there is an
infinite number of potential things that
make them different
and that's a big problem the probability
that
you've picked the one thing that makes
people who have a high fat diet
different from other people and that it
happens to be that they have a high fat
diet and that's the only difference it's
like yeah no
not not at all definitely not
so
okay so anyways
random assignation gets rid of the
problem of the infinite number of
covariates and that's worth knowing and
then the other thing that we've just
figured out is that you know if you make
a measurement you're going to get a
distribution around the measurement and
if you do that in two groups you can
check out the overlap between the two
groups and you can determine what the
probability is that that overlap is
there as a consequence of chance now you
might say
why not set your probability level
to like one in ten thousand so you could
be absolutely damn sure that the two
groups don't overlap you know so why
wouldn't you do that why wouldn't you
set p equals point zero zero zero one
instead of p equals .05 it's so that
would be one in the thousands instead of
one and twenty
yes
that's exactly right so you're basically
damned if you do and damned if you don't
which is a very important thing to
remember about life because generally
when you make a choice of any sort
there's error and risk on both sides of
the choice right it's really really
useful to remember that because people
always ask act like their current
situation is risk-free which is never
ever the case yeah so
people were trying to figure out well
how do we balance the risk of
finding something that doesn't exist
against the risk of not finding
something that exists and the reason
it's one in 20 and why is that it's
because someone made that guess 40 years
ago or 50 years ago and it's just stuck
there's no reason
and so the other thing to notice is that
you want to be careful about the p
equals 0.05 phenomena because one of the
things you'll see is that people treat
any experimental result they get like
it's significant if the probability is
0.05 or less and it's not if it's 0.06
or greater and that's
not
smart
because the cutoff is the cutoff is
arbitrary you need to know three things
to interpret an experimental result it's
like you it's like you can't calculate
the area of a triangle without knowing
three things i think it's three things
anyways um you need to know the number
of people in the study
you need to know the size of the effect
so that would be the relationship
between two or more variables that
you're interested in looking at
and then you need to know the
probability that you would find that
effect size among a population of that
size
by chance
and you cannot
interpret one of those
numbers without the other two it's not
possible and now psychologists the
st statisticians among psychologists who
have a clue have been jumping up and
down
for 50 years trying to get psychologists
to report all three of those every time
they report anything effect size which
seems logical right the effect size is
the difference between the two means
divided by the standard deviation of the
entire of the of the pooled group
well
you need both of those because it's the
standard deviation that tells you how
damn big the the numbers are because
what does 70 mean
well it doesn't mean anything 70. it's
like if i just came out here and said
that you i could say 70 and 40 are those
different
well what the hell does that mean it
doesn't mean anything
you need to know what the units are and
the distribution gives you the units and
so once you know the units are you can
say
well here's how big the difference is
between these two groups and here's the
probability that that would be acquired
by chance and so that's how
confident you could be that it's an
actual difference
and so you want to always report effect
sizes and most of you are going to be
taught to look at the damn probability
and that's stupid it's like when you
want to know how how tall how much
difference there is in height between
two people you want to know how much
difference there is in height you also
might want to know to what degree that's
there because of chance but it's the
effect size that's the critical variable
now you can't understand the effect size
without understanding how many subjects
were in the experiment and also the
probability that you would acquire that
by chance so you want to keep that in
mind and when you're reading scientific
papers you want to be looking at the
effect size how large an effect size is
this now i
all the effect sizes are you can
transform one into another so you have
correlation coefficients which go up to
one
you have the square of the correlation
coefficient which is the amount of
variance that's accounted for and that
also goes up to one and you have your
basic correlation your basic correlation
coefficients are sorry your your
standard deviation effect sizes which is
mean one minus mean two over the
standard deviation of the entire group
and so
large effect sizes in psychology i've
talked to you about this before
are correlation coefficients of about
0.5 or above or r squareds of 25 of the
variance which is 0.5 squared
or
um
mean 1 minus mean 2 of say half a
standard deviation or greater
and you can derive the
conclusion that those are relatively
large effect sizes by looking at the
distribution of the effect sizes across
the published literature
and most of you will be told estimates
for effect sizes that are actually way
too large because those were guesses too
how big's a large effect size well some
statistician guessed 50 years ago
so it's just like the 0.05 rule it's
arbitrary that doesn't mean it's stupid
but it's arbitrary and you don't want to
get stuck on it like it's like it's some
sort of fact okay so
now
let's look at
pareto distributions
that'll do
okay the first thing you're going to see
about a pareto distribution is it's
definitely not normal
now
one of the things that i mentioned to
you before but i want to hammer this
home because it's it's unbelievably
important
for determining how to understand the
way the world lays itself out
and how to interpret the way people
distribute themselves in terms of their
success across time
now this is a
this is a fundamental law and i'll show
you how it works okay so the law is
most of you get nothing and a few of you
get everything
okay so that's the law now you might say
well that's because of
you might attribute that to various
things so for example
if you're a left-winger you attribute to
it to the inequities of the social
structure and if you're a right-winger
you basically attribute to the fact that
well most people are you know not that
good at anything so it's no wonder they
end up with nothing so they're not very
smart and they're not very hard working
so they don't get
very much of whatever it is that they're
after
okay so
we'll take that apart a little bit but
before we do that i want to show you an
animation now
you got to watch this one carefully oh
yes that figures
okay yeah this thing moves very very
quickly so
we'll go back to the beginning and
all right
now so here's the deal
each of you gets ten dollars
okay so that's a non-random starting
place right you're all starting in the
same place that's definitely not random
okay now here's how you play this game
you flip a coi you turn to your partner
and you flip a coin
and if uh
it both comes up heads then you win and
they lose and if it comes up tails and
heads then you lose and they win and if
the winner gets a dollar from the loser
okay and so you can imagine that this is
a simulation so basically it's like your
apes trading bananas
if you if you if you uh give away a
banana then you're done with the banana
so one of you will walk away with 11
and one of you will walk away with nine
and then you turn to someone else you
just wander around the room and randomly
trade okay so what happens well the
first thing that happens is this
okay so we started the graph with
everyone at 10.
now you've done a bunch of trades
um we don't know how many trades you've
done but
a fair number and so what happens what
you see happening is some winners are
starting to emerge
right on the right-hand side
those are the people who've won every
single trade maybe they've traded 10
times so now they have 20
and then there's the people on the other
side who've lost
nine out of the last trades now
what what happens when you lose nine
what what's the big problem that you
have
what happens you only have one dollar
left so what happens if you lose another
trade
that's right you hit zero
and zero is not a number like any other
number
zero is like the black hole of numbers
you fall into the zero hole and that's
it you're not in the game anymore and
poverty is like that
it's like that it's a kind of a trap
that's very very difficult to get out of
so
and it seems to be in part because
once you fall off the charts enough
a bunch of things start conspiring
against you so for example
you don't have enough money to buy a
large amount of decent food cheaply
so you have to buy expensive junk food
in the short term so that might be one
possibility or let's say you end up on
the street well you can't even get a job
then because you don't have an address
and you can't get social security
because you don't have an address and
like things start to conspire against
you very badly or maybe you're
unemployed and you've been unemployed
for a year and a half because it's been
a prolonged downturn in the economy
well if you're
17 who the hell cares but if you're 50
that might be that for you right you've
hit zero you've been out of the market
for 18 months nobody's gonna hire you
and so you've hit zero
and the problem is
we don't know what the hell to do when
people hit zero it's difficult to pry
them out of zero and throw them back in
the game
now you could say well what if you just
rearm them with money and that would
actually work if the game was truly
random
but it isn't obvious that the game is
truly random and that's where things get
weird okay so anyways by this point in
the game there's some winners piling up
and there's some losers piling up what
what's the difference between the people
who have 19 and the people who have won
well we know the one people they're
going to be wiped out they got a 50
percent chance of hitting zero what
about the 19 people
they've got a much better chance of not
hitting zeros because
they'd have to fail one more right
exactly so they're in this place where
they're basically sitting pretty they
can fail nine times and that just puts
them back to where they were to begin
with
so okay so we keep playing
okay
well so you see what's happening is that
with repeated
random play
the normal distribution turns into a
pareto distribution and most of the
population stacks up at zero
hmm
okay
this old guy i told you about
he had a theory of social structure that
was predicated on this there's a bit of
a marxist twist to it he thought that
what happened is that so if you ran a
game long enough
most people will stack up at zero and a
few people have everything okay so let's
say now you're down at zero
what's your best strategy
well you might say well we should reset
the game
right because if you're at zero and it's
basically a random game
if you wipe out that game and you put
another one in place there's some
probability that when the next game
starts playing you're not going to end
up at zero and that was his theory of
revolutions fundamentally
once the once the game had played itself
out and until resources were maximally
distributed it didn't cost the people at
the bottom anything to be
revolutionaries because they had already
hit zero
and so one of his hypotheses was that
one of the things that
political and economic systems have to
do they have to figure out how to do is
to
make sure that the people who end up on
the
zero side of the distribution
don't have nothing to lose
because if you have nothing to lose god
only knows what you're going to do next
now it's a big problem because
merely shoveling money down there is not
likely to change the outcome very much
yes
like if you
because once you've reset the game your
probability of ending up with zero is
exactly the same as the first time yeah
but the probability that any given
person will end up at zero is the same
but the probability that you'll end up
the same isn't
because at the beginning of the game you
have just as much probability of moving
up to the top as you do it moving down
to the bottom once you're at zero though
you don't get to play anymore
so at zero your probability of moving up
is zero
whereas at the beginning your
probability of moving up is fifty
percent
so when the gambler's fallacy is merely
that if you keep dumping good money
after bad you'll win it back you know
because let's say you've lost 10 times
in a row you think well i've lost 10
times in a row it's 50 50. i must have a
virtually 100 chance of winning the next
time it's like well no you don't because
probability doesn't have any memory
that's the gambler's fallacy
so
all right now
one of the things we might ask ourselves
is
this is something that i that i
discussed with him in late because he
really thought of this as a random
process
and you know because he he thought he
it's very very interesting and very
complicated it's like we know for
example that the iq distribution in this
room is approximately normal
and so we could assume that it's a
consequence of random factors okay so
what what do we mean random factors well
there have been random genetic things
going on in your lineage since life
began
and here you are you know you're smarter
than him
perhaps why well we're going to
eliminate the environmental effects for
now just forget about them we're going
to assume that everybody's been raised
in an environment where they had enough
to eat and where they have enough
resources
um informational resources so that their
intellect can capitalize so none of you
people have been starved for information
or food so i would say in many ways the
important variation in the environment
has already been ironed out for most of
you not completely
okay so it's random occurrences in the
past in the evolutionary history that's
put you wherever the hell you are in the
iq distribution
so you're the beneficiary of random
forces
so he thought of the problem as being
random all the way down to the bottom
now the problem i had with that is wait
a second we have evidence
that some things predict where you're
going to end up in the distribution
and so what are those things
well iq
conscientiousness
emotional stability
openness if it's a creative product and
then some other smattering of
personality features depending on the
particular domain so for example if you
want to be a salesperson some extra
version is you is useful if you want to
be a manager it tends to be better if
you're disagreeable to some degree
rather than if you're agreeable if you
want to be a nurse or a caretaker then
agreeableness is useful but the big
performance predictors across time are
intelligence and
conscientiousness now
if the damn game is random
which the statistics seem to indicate or
at least that you can model it using
processes that model random processes
why in the world do iq and
conscientiousness we'll just stick with
those two for now why in the world do
they predict success
so does anybody have any ideas about
that
let's start with iq
i mean for example if you apply your iq
to the stock market
if i distribute you all a bunch of money
and i and i measured your iq and i said
okay put together a portfolio
you get to pick 30 stocks you can't sell
them for a year you get to sell them at
the end of the year
um what's the probability that the high
iq people would pick a better set of
stocks than the low iq people
the answer to that as far as i can tell
is zero
it's not it's not gonna because you
can't pick stocks
as it turns out all the information is
already eaten up
so i can and the stock market's an
interesting analogy of the environment
right you know what i mean because the
stock market is basically an index of
the continually transforming human
economic and social environment it's
basically random you can't predict the
damn thing even if you're smart
so why is it that smart people win
across time and then again why is it
that hard working people win across time
if we imagine each peg on the galton
board as like a choice point in life
then i think the people with a higher iq
are more likely to choose the choice
point that will leave them you know now
but that's only a restatement of what i
just said it's not a causal account
you're basically saying that the high iq
people make better choices yeah but
that's if it's a random environment how
can they
i'm thinking instead of money we can
view it as
opportunities and genetics which make
somebody adoptable in multiple
environments and each coin flip as each
subsequent generation
of that lineage
so that
there is an increase
like the more good adaptable genetics
emotional stability and situational
wealth you have the more likely
your next generation has you know like
they have to lose a lot more to get to
the zero
okay so what what about a given
individual though
forget about forget about it playing
across time and that's also a weird
thing because some of the single-celled
organisms that you that were your
ancestors three billion years ago are
still single-celled organisms
whereas here you are
you know same environment roughly
speaking so there's this tremendous
branching of possibility across time and
you might say well iq is adaptive which
is a terrible word adaptive it's like
yeah okay so how do you account for all
the single-celled organisms they're just
not that bright but there they are
there's broad there's more of them by
weight than there are of us people by
weight so
i puzzled this out a bunch of different
ways and you can you can think about
this and see what you think i mean the
first thing that seems to me to be the
case is that you don't have to play one
game
you know like imagine that you're
sitting around with your friends
and there are 50 board games going on
and you can keep a hand in in each of
them
well then
at some point in one of the board games
you're going to start to amass some
success right just by chance and if
you're playing 50 board games in 25 of
them after playing for some time you're
going to be at the top of it you know
you're going to be moving towards the
top 50 rather than the bottom
we might say okay play 50 games
play 20 turns throw away the ones that
you're doing the worst in the five
percent that you're doing the worst in
and then just keep doing that until you
end up with the one game that you win
and maybe you can do that better if you
have high iq because you're faster
so maybe you all you can all that
happens is that if you're smart is that
you can play many games faster and as a
consequence of that you can choose the
ones that you seem to be winning and
stick with those
and then maybe what happens with
conscientiousness is that you actually
stick to them
so that means that you actually don't
have to predict the future in order to
master it it means that you have to
simulate multiple futures keep your
options open and sort of play
dynamically as the environment unfolds
so
now it might be more complicated than
that because it's also possible that in
some
environments at least for local periods
of time
the
the game is actually not random
you know so
it's it's funny like do you think is
monopoly random
what do you think you've all who
everybody here has played monopoly i
presume right is there anybody who
hasn't
okay so what do you think do the smart
people win monopoly more often
i think it's the people
you do you think so you would say it's
the conscientious people that win more
often
yeah well it's pretty clear that you can
you can lose stupidly in monopoly
right although i'm not sure if you can
win intelligently
you know you can avoid
obviously bad choices like one choice
would be don't buy any property and just
hold on to your money that seems to be a
losing strategy right so that'll wipe
you out so maybe another thing that
smart people can do is that they don't
do things that are self-evidently
that make it certain that you'll lose it
might be something like that
so
all right so one of the things we might
ask ourselves too is
given that iq and and conscientiousness
do predict success how much success do
they predict across time and the answer
to that is
they predict a substantial amount
if you combine iq and
personality
i'll show you the equations these were
formulated in the 1990s
so we're going to look at this here so
um
let me walk you through it a bit
so this is a spreadsheet i put together
quite a long time ago
get this a little bigger so you can see
it
all right
so here's what
here's the elements of the of the
equation
so you need to know
first element of the equation
how many people so we're going to say
well how powerfully can you predict the
performance outcome of people across
time and what they
the value we're going to use is dollar
value
and dollars are basically
they're sort of like uh they're
obviously they're the universal currency
because you can trade money in for
virtually anything so we use dollars as
our standard of value
the first question might be well how
many people do you want to predict for
so let's say we're going to take 10 so
we put that in this part of the equation
here 10 people then you might say well
over what period of time do you want to
calculate their success and one decent
answer is five years because people seem
to stay in the same
job position or career position for
about five years although that's
shortening okay so that's another thing
that you guys should keep in mind you're
probably not going to be in the same
position in your life for more than
about five years at a time and so you
have to plan and plot for dynamic
transformations in your career and you
have to do that in a way that um
that that works to your advantage which
partly means you have to keep options
open and you have to be able to say no
so
okay the next thing you might ask
yourself is well how high a predictor
what's the r for your predictor what's
the correlation coefficient and we put
together a neuropsychological battery um
i published the results of this with a
with a
uh someone named daniel higgins quite a
long time ago we used neuropsychological
battery looking at dorsolateral
prefrontal ability which we thought of
as something potentially separate from
fluid intelligence which prob but which
probably just turned out to be quite a
good measure of fluid intelligence and
we also used conscientiousness and we
found that when we validated that in a
we we validated it in a factory and and
we looked at the performance of the
administrators and managers in the
factory because they had relatively
complex jobs and we had access to seven
years of their performance records which
someone else had gathered independently
of us and what we found was that
for those people who had performance
records that were more than four years
old we could predict their performance
at about 0.59
about about 0.6
tremendously powerful prediction now one
of the things we found was that
the degree to which our predictions were
accurate increased with the increase in
the number of years of performance data
we have so for example if i want to
predict how you do next year and i get a
performance in you you enter a new job
and i get a performance index after your
first year i'm not going to be able to
predict that very well from your
intelligence and your conscientiousness
because the measure of your performance
actually won't be very good because it
turns out that you can't even figure out
how well someone is performing in a job
until about three years
so it turns out that if you take a
complex job on
you get better and better at it over
three years if you're going to get
better and better at it and so we can't
tell how well you're doing until about
that period of time so that's another
thing that's useful to know by the way
when you guys go off to find your next
complex role in life
you can't really expect to be good at
what you're going to do until about
three years after about four years
additional experience doesn't seem to
matter
so that's also worth knowing so you're
going to feel like a bloody for
the first bit of your new job and that's
because you are but you
you if you keep at it you'll accrue
um experience and and and expertise
quite rapidly over a three year period
and that's probably the right amount of
time over which to evaluate your
performance because you need to know
that right should you be freaking out if
after six months you're not doing a good
job well
you've got to see how you're doing
compared to your peers
hopefully you're not doing a worse job
than them but if it's a complex job it's
going to take you a long time to master
it
so okay so anyways our predictor was
0.59 which we're pretty damn thrilled
about
and we're comparing that we're going to
compare that to a
comparison predictor of zero for now
zero is random
so if i was going to predict your
trajectory through life let's say i want
to predict your industrial productivity
i'll take ten of you i'm gonna
i'm going to predict your industrial
productivity over the next five years
that's that'll be the goal um
or we can do this i will do this a
slightly different way um let's see so
that's the selection ratio the last one
is the selection ratio so let's say
um
i wanted to select you guys for a
position at a well let's say you're
going to be managers in a in a
in a relatively complex
corporate organization there's about a
hundred and
ten of you or something like that in
here now maybe let's say a hundred say
i'm going to pick 10 of you
that means my selection ratio is
right there it's one
it's it's one in ten that you can
transform that into a standard score of
1.76
now it's important to know how many
people you get to choose from because
if you're going to hire one person and
you only have one applicant there's not
a lot of sense doing any selection
because you only have one applicant so i
don't care how much you know about that
person it's not going to be helpful if
you have to hire them but in this
situation we're going to assume that i
can screen all 100 of you and only
recommend 10.
okay
so
we're going to assume you have to put in
a variable for job complexity
because the relationship between
intelligence and conscientiousness
increases the relationship between
intelligence conscientiousness and
predictive power increases as the job
becomes more complicated which is
exactly what you'd expect right so if
you can do a job by rote all that iq and
conscientiousness will predict is how
fast you can learn it
but if it's a dynamic job where you have
to make decisions on a non-stop basis
then iq and conscientiousness are going
to predict your performance over the
long run
so we're going to assume that you're in
a complex job we're going to assume that
you have an annual salary of 75 000
so then the question is armed with that
knowledge
how much
money would the company that's using my
products
obtain by using the selection compared
to with if they just picked 10 of you
randomly and the answer is
right there
in five years
they would have made
four million dollars more than they
would have if they would have just
picked randomly
and that would be a productivity
increase of 104 percent
so
there that's graphed here
with random selection
50 percent of the people you hire are
going to be above average and 50
are going to be below
and using a good psychometric battery
you can get that to about 80 20.
and the consequence of that is
4 million dollars in increased
productivity so now we're going to turn
that into one person
so over five years
if you use selection processes properly
you make four hundred thousand dollars
more by hiring one better person
right it's forty thousand dollar it's
what is that it's a hundred thousand
dollars a year it's actually more than
you're paying them in celery
and now the reason for that is bunch of
reasons
the first reason is is that there are
tremendous amounts there's tremendous
differences in individual productivity
now one of the things that's weird about
these formulas is this formula is
predicated on the idea that productivity
is actually normally distributed
but actually productivity is paredo
distributed so what that means is that
the basic consequence of using this sort
of prediction is probably higher than
this formula
indicates
now
there's a variety of reasons to know
this one is obviously the practical idea
the practical idea is
of what use is it knowing something
about the people that you're going to
hire
and that's or work with and the answer
to that is it depends on what you know
but if the things that you know are
valid
and they include personality and
intelligence
it's not only
valuable to know it it's virtually vital
because the success of your enterprise
will depend on
the people that you hire and associate
with
the second thing is i think that
knowing this should change the way that
you look at the world
if you understand that
the outcomes in life are distributed on
a pareto distribution
and that there are
inbuilt temperamental factors that play
an important role in determining that
one of the problems that you have before
you as modern people is what the hell do
you do about that from a conceptual
social political and economic
perspective because nobody
who's currently
considering how societies are structured
pays any attention to this sort of thing
they don't assume that there are
differences between people with regards
to their life outcome chances not of
this sort of magnitude
and so none of the social policies that
we have in place reflect any of this
and so i would say like our
psychometrics our 21st century and our
political and economic theories are
basically 17th century and it's not a
good thing and you guys are going to
suffer for this or benefit from it
because
as
society becomes more technological and
as it transforms more and more rapidly
the degree to which the pareto
distribution is going to kick in is
going to increase now you already see
that
that's why
the the separation between rich and poor
in industrialized countries is becoming
increasingly
severe now
that's
modified by some degree to the fact by
the fact that the middle class worldwide
is growing like mad and so that's a
really good thing but still the
long-term play is the pareto
distribution and it's partly because
an intelligent person is one thing but
an intelligent person with infinite
computational power that's a completely
different thing and that's where we're
headed
so i don't know exactly what to make of
all this sort of thing politically but i
know that
to the degree that we ignore it
we're going to have very unhappy and
and
unstable societies
so
we'll see you thursday on that happy
note we'll see you thursday